>> Ron Charles: We are all going
to take out our cell phones
and turn them off now.
OK. Good. I'm Ron Charles.
I write about books
for the Washington Post
where I also host the
Totally Hip Video Book Review.
First, a word of thanks to our
cochairman of this festival,
David Rubenstein, and the other
generous sponsors who've made
this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in your program.
We'll have some time after this
conversation for your questions.
And I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone, you will
be included in the videotape
of this event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
Our guest this afternoon
is Deborah Harkness.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Now as you may have
heard...as you may have heard,
there's a witch hunt
going on in Washington.
[ Laughter ]
Some old man keeps
nattering on about that.
>> Whoa!
>> Ron Charles: Well,
today, it's true.
But it has nothing to
do with Robert Mueller.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Harkness is a
professor at the University
of Southern California,
historian of science
and medicine with a particular
interest in the period of 1400
to 1700, which if you know
your history, was a really,
really bad time to be a witch.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Harkness has
published scholarly work
on the 16th-century
alchemist John Dee,
the Scientific Revolution
in England,
female medical practices,
and even the development
of accounting.
[ Laughter ]
She's received fellowships
from the Guggenheim Foundation,
the National Science Foundation,
the National Humanities Center.
So this is clearly a scholar who
knows her way around a library.
But then a bewitching
thing happened
to her about ten years ago.
"I began to wonder," she says,
"what if there really
are witches and vampires?
What would they do
for a living?"
[ Laughter ]
It was at that moment she
turned from the dusty world
of academics and wrote a
magical novel called A Discovery
of Witches about
the relationship
between a historian
descended from Salem witches
and a 15-year-old --
1,500-year-old vampire.
[ Laughter ]
That's a whole different
story, yeah.
Sorry. I'm reading fast
because I want to get her
up here as soon as possible.
An international best
selling trilogy was born,
the All Souls Trilogy, which
eventually included Shadow
of Night in 2012 and The
Book of Life in 2014.
And her new book, A Discovery
of Witches, has been --
her first book, A Discovery
of Witches, has been adopted
into a TV series that
will be broadcast
in the United States
early next year.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And in a few weeks,
she'll publish a new novel
called Time's Convert.
[ Applause ]
Which through magic of
my own, I have a copy
of that she has never seen
before, and it is signed.
We have some fans
here, I suspect?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
OK. What is Marcus's [assumed
spelling] astrological sign?
>> Aries.
>> Ron Charles: I
don't hear the answer.
>> Aries.
>> Pices. Virgo!
[ Laughter and Indistinct
Chatter ]
>> Sagittarius!
>> Ron Charles: They're
just guessing now.
OK. In what town
was Marcus born?
>> Hadley, Massachusetts.
>> Ron Charles: Yes!
Who said that?
The book is yours!
Come on up.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
witches and warlocks,
I give you Deborah Harkness.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Deborah Harkness: You can't
get away with guessing like that
with a professor in the room.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, thank you, Ron, for
that lovely introduction,
and thanks to all of
you guys for coming
out to this amazing event.
It's the first time I've been
at the National Book Festival,
and it is such a
treat be to here
to celebrate the
special relationship
between books and readers.
So I think that it's fair to
say that if you're in this room,
you are a reader, right?
[ Applause ]
Which means that these are
now, you know, several hundred
of your best friends
because everybody
in the room shares that.
And there's nothing like books
and sharing our favorite books
to sort of bring
people close together.
And that's what's so amazing
about the National
Book Festival,
based on what I've seen already.
So as Ron said -- and I'm sure
that comes as news to nobody
in the room, I am
not only an author,
but I'm also a professor.
And I am a specific
kind of professor.
You know, there's a sort of tree
of knowledge out
there in history.
There's all these fields
and subfields and subfields.
So when people say,
well, do you teach?
I always say, Europe
between 1400 and 1700.
And they said OK, yeah, but
-- you know, so Louis the XIV?
And I say, no, no,
not Louis XIV.
I mostly teach the 16th century.
And they say, oh,
OK, Henry VIII?
And I'm like, kind of, but
usually I teach, you know,
the history of science
and medicine,
which makes me an
intellectual historian.
And people always say, and
intellectual historian?
Yeah, I study how people
think about the world
and their place in it.
That's what intellectual
history is really all about.
And I became an intellectual
historian basically
when I was a sophomore
in college.
Everybody in the room
probably can remember a teacher
who may have asked
them a pivotal question
at some point in
their education.
For me, it was a professor named
Harold Gare Goodyear [phonetic],
and he asked in a class on
magic in the Renaissance --
talk about the shape
of things to come --
he asked, how do you know
what you think you know?
And I still remember
to this day --
I remember the table in the
library where I was sitting
when he asked that question.
I remember which chair I was in.
Because I felt like the whole
top of my head lifted off.
How do I know what
I think I know?
That was the beginning
of my journey
into intellectual history
and the history of science.
But of course, even though
I've gone from European history
to the 16th century to
intellectual history
and the history of science,
there's even a further,
weird subspecialty of mine;
and that subspecialty is
the history of the book.
What the history of the book is,
is a little less
self-explanatory
than the history of
science and medicine.
Basically, the history of
the book studies what it is
that we're here celebrating,
this special relationship
between books and readers.
[ Applause ]
But it's -- yeah.
So for those of you who are
really into reading yourself,
you should know that there's
a whole historical field
that is dedicated
to you in the past.
So I actually -- like, if you
really burrow down closely,
my real research
specialty is, how did people
in the past share
information about science
and medicine in their notebooks?
That's what I really
do for a living.
[ Applause ]
Talk about the head
of a pin here.
So the history of the book, it
includes how books were made,
who wrote books,
how they were sold,
the technologies of printing.
Papermaking is included in
the history of the book,
ink making -- for those of you
who remember Diana buying ink
in London in Shadow of Night,
is included in the
history of the book.
The transition from
manuscript culture
to print culture is included
in the history of the book.
You might be entertained to know
that when the printing
press was invented,
people thought it was the end
of civilization as we knew it.
[ Laughter ]
Because no one would
remember how to write anymore.
And when I was listening to all
of the debates about e-readers
and electronic books, and
it was the end of the world,
I was so reminded of what
people thought at the end
of the 15th century when
printing presses were set up
and put a whole lot of scribes
who had been handwriting
books --
imagine that for a
job -- out of work.
And people said it's
the end of the world,
it's the end of civilization.
So these are some of
the things that we study
as historians of the book.
And for those of
you who are readers
of the All Souls Trilogy,
what you're probably realizing
is you've picked up a lot
of information about the history
of the book in your travels.
So you may have thought you
were just getting history,
political history, history
of science and medicine.
You were getting my great love,
which is the history
of the book as well.
Now in the history of the book,
there are things that are harder
to come to terms
with than others.
It's pretty easy
for us, for example,
to figure out what
books were published
in X year in any given country.
One of the things that I
used to do for fun was to go
through the Library of
Congress's lists of all
of the books that were
published in a given year
in England and then read them.
[ Laughter ]
Because it was maybe a couple
hundred titles back in the day
when printing was
still a new technology.
And it was a great way
to learn about a culture.
That all worked its way into
Shadow of Night as well.
If you think about her
going book shopping
and seeing those
books on the counter
at the local apothecary's shop.
So it's easy for
us to get access
to things like, what
did people buy?
It's even easy for us to
get access into what kinds
of things they marked
up in their books.
I wrote a whole book
about the annotations
that Queen Elizabeth's
court astrologer, John Dee,
what annotations he made in his
scientific and medical books.
However, there's something
that's very hard for historians
of the book to get access to,
and it's the thing we most want
to know, which is what was
the experience of reading
like for people in the past?
So you can do a little thought
experiment here with me.
Just close your eyes
for a minute and try
to remember a sort of important
reading memory that you have.
It could be a memory
from childhood.
It could be a recent memory.
It could be something
that you experienced
where you had a strong
negative reaction to a book
or a strong positive
reaction to a book.
Think about how old you were.
Think about where you were
when you were reading it,
when it was in your life.
Do you remember anything
else about it?
Do you remember how you
felt at that moment?
What you've just conjured
up is the Holy Grail
for book historians.
It is the moment when the
reader and the text connect.
And of all the things I study,
that is the thing I most want
to understand and where I
can find very little evidence
in the 16th century that helps
me understand what it was
like for one of Shakespeare's
contemporaries
to essentially pick
up a book and read it.
Because what we know is
they didn't read like us.
Some of them didn't
read silently.
Often, you read aloud to
people and shared texts orally.
We're not really sure
if you even bought,
for example, books
as whole books.
Some people, it's clear,
bought pieces of books
and then had them
stitched together later
because they couldn't afford
the whole text at one time.
So for me, my memory
is a memory of being --
it was 1973, so I would
have been eight years old.
I was visiting my
mother's family in England.
I was in my cousin Sharon's
[assumed spelling] upstairs
bedroom sitting on the bed,
and my aunt Sylvia [assumed
spelling] gave me a copy of Anne
of Avonlea that had
been my mother's
when she was growing up.
And it had, "If this book
should chance to roam,
just box its ears
and send it home
to Olive Riddell [phonetic],"
which is my mother's name.
And there was a lovely
drawing of a woman's face.
I had no idea at the age of
eight my mother could draw.
And I remember that the pages
in the book smelled like toffee.
They were sort of
that funny paper
that turns brown really fast.
Because my mother grew up
in Liverpool during the war,
and so paper was pretty scarce
and it wasn't of high quality.
And to this day, I
remember sitting on that bed
in that second-floor room
with my mother's copy of Anne
of Avonlea and feeling connected
to the book, to my mother,
to a whole world
outside of Liverpool.
And, you know, I've read
hundreds and hundreds of books
in my life, but that
is my memory.
And now that I've said it to all
of you, hopefully at some point,
somewhere, it will actually
be recorded, and it will exist
for future historians who
are looking for what was it
like to be a reader
in the 20th century.
So I started with this story
of the history of the books
because of the ways
that my fictional world,
the All Souls world, is
a world that is built
around books and readers.
It is a world that is
filled with libraries,
from the Strahov Library in
Prague to John Dee's library
at Mortlake to the
Bodleian Library,
to the Beinecke Library.
It's filled with texts that
have very close relationships
with the people who
touched them.
There's a reason why in the
third book of the trilogy
that when Diana finally
gets the whole Book of Life,
it enters into her and
changes her forever.
That's because that's how I
feel when I read a book, right?
It gets into me and
it changes me forever.
So when I was thinking
about what I would do
after I finished the
All Souls Trilogy --
other than have a rest, other
than work with a wonderful team
of authors on The World of All
Souls Encyclopedia for you all,
I was trying to think about how
I could continue in the world
of the trilogy and what my
path forward might look like.
And not surprisingly, I turned
to the history of the book.
And I started to
think about the ways
in which we are what we read,
just like we are what we eat.
That our reading shapes
us, just as Diana's contact
with the Book of
Life shaped her.
I think I was influenced
a bit by this
because I was teaching the
history of the book at the time,
and I was teaching a book that
is still fairly controversial
by Irving Leonard called
Books of the Brave.
And Irving Leonard
was interested
in how the conquistadors
coming from Spain
to the New World spent
their time on ships.
And he looked through various
ship inventories to look
to see what books were
on board these ships
for this very long voyage going
from Spain to the New World.
And we're in the perfect
place to discuss this.
Guess what he found?
He found that the number
one reading material --
there was always a
copy of the Bible.
But other than that, these
ships that were going from Spain
to the New World were
filled with genre fiction.
They were filled with chivalric
romances, tales of King Arthur,
and knights going on quests.
And what Irving Leonard
argued was that you can see
in the way the conquistadors
conceptualized what they were
doing in the New World, which
seems to be at such a distance
from what we as modern observers
see looking back at the evidence
of what they did to
the native populations.
We see a tale that is a tale
of brutality and a failure
of empathy and a lack
of understanding.
What the conquistadors saw
in themselves were people
on a heroic quest to look for
-- to spread the word of God.
People who were looking
to have adventure
and to meet magical creatures,
all of which were in
the genre fiction.
Now of course people
aren't only what they read.
A lot of other things
go into it as well.
But I was struck by
the ways in which --
the question of are you
what you read might be able
to help me get into my
characters' backstories.
And I had a little bit of
a trial balloon with this.
For those of you who read The
World of All Souls, when we came
to write the section on Matthew
and his ideas about science --
Matthew's a 1,500-year-old
vampire, as you heard,
and so he's read a
lot of science books.
And when the author team
met to talk about The World
of All Souls, they
said, Deb, you know,
you've got to write an overview
of Matthew's scientific ideas
and where they came from.
And I just thought it was going
to be stupefyingly
boring to do that.
And I'm an educator, so I have
kind of an idea of what's going
to be stupefyingly boring.
[ Laughter ]
So I said, oh, gosh, you
know, I don't want to do that.
But you know what, I could
tell you what were some
of the most pivotal reading
moments in Matthew's life,
what books influenced him, like
me reading that copy of Anne
of Avonlea that belonged
to my mother.
And so we put books on an
imaginary bookshelf that I felt
like Matthew would have had a
really strong connection with.
And once I did it with
Matthew, I wanted to do it
with other characters as well.
So that brings us
to Time's Convert,
to the new book that's coming
out in just a few weeks.
Time's Convert, the title of
the book, comes from a line
from Thomas Paine's
Common Sense.
Time makes more converts
than reason.
And when I was trying
to imagine the books
that Marcus would have read
up until the time he
became a vampire in 1781,
Common Sense was
definitely on that list,
but there were others as well.
So the person who won the
book, Tracy, knows that one
of the things that Marcus
is is a child from Hadley.
Hadley, Massachusetts, was on
the frontier of the colonies
in the 18th century
when Marcus was born.
Incidentally, he is a Leo.
[ Laughter ]
But he would have been taught
to read reading something
called a primer or a primer.
And the Library of
Congress has amazing copies
of the New England Primer,
if you're ever in Washington
and you get a chance to
go or to look at them
on their digital collections.
They were books that
had little verses
for children to read
and memorize.
They often had words of
praise about the King.
They had words of one syllable,
words of two syllables,
words of three syllables,
little parables.
And that's how somebody
like Marcus would
have learned to read.
What's amazing to us
is if we look back
at those vocabulary lists where
it's like, God and King and lady
and courage, words that we
wouldn't necessarily maybe think
would be sort of the
words that you would put
in a children's reading
guide appear on the list.
When Marcus finished learning
to read, he would have gone
from primers to almanacs,
the bullet journals
of the 18th century.
Almost every house
had an almanac in it.
It gave you the roads in
and outs of major cities,
it told you when major
agricultural fairs were coming.
It told you about big
events, big events in the life
of the nation, which at that
point was Great Britain.
The birthdate of the King
was almost always highlighted
in red in an almanac.
So Marcus would have had one
of those almanacs in
his house as well.
He might have had an
adventure story or two.
One of the most popular books
in the 18th century was
Robinson Caruso, and the stories
of adventure were
highly abbreviated.
They weren't reading
the Robinson Crusoe
if you read it in English lit.
That wasn't the version
they were reading.
They were reading a really
sort of highly adapted,
shorter version of the story
that was really geared
towards children.
As he got older, Marcus would
have moved to newspapers.
Newspapers were the lifeblood
of print culture
in the US colonies.
And again, the Library
of Congress has online the
most amazing collection
of 18th-century newspapers.
Remember how I told you I used
to read, like, a whole year
of 16th-century books
at a clip to see
if I could learn
something about the past?
When I wrote Time's
Convert, I sat down
and started reading
colonial newspapers.
And it was an amazing experience
to see that on the front page
of the newspaper were all
the advertisements for coffee
and chips, and the
political news is buried
on pages two and three.
[ Laughter ]
Totally different than what
we think are the headlines
for an 18th-century audience.
And of course, Common
Sense, this classic work
of the American Revolution
started its life
as a newspaper column.
It was first published in
installments in newspapers,
which is how Marcus would have
first come into contact with it.
And then Marcus having
read a bit of Common Sense
in the newspaper that would have
been passed around in his town
of Hadley that would have
been in some ways shocking
to the conservative town that he
grew up in that called for life
and liberty and equality
in really strong terms.
Those words worked their way
into Marcus's bloodstream
and turned him into a patriot
who fought at Bunker Hill.
So there's Marcus's mini
bookshelf: the primer,
an almanac, Robinson Caruso,
a folded-up newspaper,
a worn copy of Time's Convert
-- of Time's Convert --
[ Laughter ]
-- Common Sense, where the
title Time's Convert comes from.
And it was drawing those texts
together that gave me hope
that with all of the characters
in the All Souls Trilogy,
be they witches or demons or
vampires, that I had a way
of connecting to them for
you and getting their stories
on the page that would
illuminate this world of books
and readers and characters
for you in a way
that would be interesting
and have something fun to say
about them and about us.
Because I do want to continue
with the All Souls world,
but I never want to be the
person who when you walk
into your bookstore, your
eyes roll, and you say, oh,
God, there's another one.
[ Laughter ]
Right? I always want
it to be an experience
that somehow captures a bit
of that first-time magic some
of you felt when you were
reading A Discovery of Witches.
So don't be surprised
if you see more books
in the All Souls world --
[ Applause ]
-- and don't be surprised
if you're getting a lot
of the history of the
book in them as you read.
Because really, that's
what we are at heart,
a community of booklovers
and book readers.
So I want to at this
point invite you guys --
I've saved a lot of
time for questions
because I thought
there might be some.
So we've got about, wow, 15
or 20 minutes for questions.
So does anybody have any, please
come on up to the microphone.
If nobody has them, I
will just riff for you.
Oh, good. This is the moment
in a teacher's life that's
very anxiety producing.
Questions?
Yes?
>> Hi. I first encountered
your books via audiobooks.
>> Deborah Harkness: Yeah.
>> And they're beautiful
pieces performance in my view.
[ Applause ]
>> Deborah Harkness: Hear, hear.
>> And I'm curious given
your historical perspective
on the history of the book,
where you see books going.
I'm a first-generation Kindle
owner, so I kind of understand,
you know, you chuckling
at the Chicken Little
perspective on e-readers.
So I'm interested to hear where
you think we're going from here.
>> Deborah Harkness: You know,
if you had told me even five
years ago how popular audiobooks
and Kindle books would become,
I think I would have
been surprised.
But even more surprising
is the renaissance
of independent bookstores
that's happening.
[ Applause ]
So what I think is -- what I'm
seeing a lot of is almost a --
there's a name for it.
It's called platform agnostic
readers, which basically means,
I'll read anything on anything.
[ Laughter ]
I'll read it in hardback
and paperback and audiobook
and Kindle, and that's what
I think is so exciting.
So I'm trying to imagine
what the next evolution
of that might be.
As somebody who thought
email was silly,
I'm probably the worst person
to ask about the future.
[ Laughter ]
But it is intriguing to think
about the ways that, you know,
how an audiobook and a
textual book and, you know,
a visual adaptation of the book
might someday fuse together.
And you could go back and forth
between them, which is, I think,
what a lot of people
do who have e-books.
They are bouncing
back between their car
and their Kindle
and their paperback.
And I think that's
really what we're going
to see in the future.
>> Thank you.
>> Deborah Harkness:
Great question.
>> Quick follow-up.
>> Deborah Harkness: Yeah.
>> Serpent's Mirror?
>> Deborah Harkness:
So Serpent's Mirror.
Who has questions about
the Serpent's Mirror?
So the Serpent's Mirror.
The Serpent's Mirror is a book
about Matthew in
the 16th century.
And it covers Matthew's
life under Henry VIII
and Mary Tudor and Elizabeth.
And it turned out to be way
more complicated a story
than I thought.
And about halfway through --
I have about 225
pages of it written.
And Matthew did something
very surprising,
and it brought me up short.
And I started working on
the Marcus book as a kind
of antidote as I worked
out the Matthew problem,
and the Marcus book
was finished first.
So I had a choice at that
point whether I was going
to give you the Marcus
book first or just hold it,
and I decided I would
give it to you.
[ Applause ]
But Serpent's Mirror is coming.
I promise.
Yeah?
>> First of all, I
want to thank you
for how very responsive
you are with your fans --
>> Deborah Harkness:
Oh, you got it.
>> -- especially on Facebook.
That's awesome and
we appreciate it.
>> Deborah Harkness: Thanks.
>> So I also wanted to
ask about Gallowglass.
He's my favorite
character and [laughs] --
>> Deborah Harkness: I've
never heard that before.
You are the first person
who's ever liked Gallowglass.
Thank you.
Joke [laughs].
>> Is he getting a book, please?
>> Deborah Harkness: I think
Galloglass will get a book.
[ Applause ]
I spent two wonderful weeks this
summer sailing around Ireland
and Scotland in a boat to get
a little closer to Galloglass.
So he now has been advanced
to the official position
of having a notebook devoted
to him, which is the first step
in the book being -- now
you know I'm not fast,
so please nobody look
for this for Christmas.
It's not going to happen.
[ Laughter ]
But he will get his book.
He will get his moment
in the sun.
I promise.
Yeah?
>> Hi. So one of the things
that I enjoyed the most
about the entire
trilogy was the way
that you were layering
history and science and all
of these things on
top of each other.
And so I was actually wondering
if you could talk a little bit
about the difficulty
of world-building
over actual history?
>> Deborah Harkness: Yeah.
Great question.
So as a historian, as you
can imagine, I have a kind
of fairly allergic
reaction to history going
out the window, be
it in anything.
And so the way I
felt about it was --
and it may be a little
different for other people
who write historical fiction.
I felt like if something was
knowable to me as a historian,
that's what it needed
to be in the book.
But if something was unknowable,
like what was Kit Marlowe
[phonetic] doing on Halloween
in 1590, I could invent it.
So I'll give you an example
of how that played out.
Matthew Roydon, who was a
real person and was part
of my research for
my master's thesis,
which was on George
Chapman's Shadow of Night.
Any of that sound familiar?
He was this annoying, hanging
chad of my master's thesis
who the Shadow of Night was
dedicated to him, but he was,
like, the Forrest Gump
of the 16th century.
But I couldn't find any real
concrete information about him.
So I thought, well,
he's perfect,
that's exactly what a
vampire would be like.
I'm going to use Matthew Roydon.
So actually even in Discovery
of Witches, you were falling
in love with a 16th-century
dead poet.
Because I use whatever I
knew about Matthew Roydon
to shape Matthew
Clermont's character.
Because he was this sort
of fixed, historical thing.
Then as I started writing it, I
thought, well, Shadow of Night,
they're there in October,
they'll be out by Christmas.
And as I kept writing, as
I do, in my loop de loops,
and we got closer and closer
into spring, I thought, oh, no.
Because one of the other things
I knew about Matthew Roydon was
that he was in Prague
in March and April.
I had no intention
of going to Prague.
We were going to go to
London and come back.
But as the plot unfolded, I
said, I'm sorry, the book --
you know, it's going
to take me longer.
I have to go to Prague.
[ Laughter ]
And people said, what do you
mean you have to go to Prague?
And I said, Matthew
Roydon went to Prague.
It's now March.
I have to go to Prague.
And they said, no one
knows that but you.
[ Laughter ]
And I said, I know, but I know
it, and I can't un-know it.
And so that's sort of my
relationship with history.
So people keep saying to
me, well, why is Marcus --
when they read the drafts
of Time's Convert --
why is Marcus in that
battle and not this battle?
Because that's what was
happening and I'm not going
to sort of rearrange history.
So I almost think of it
as like a pinball machine.
You know how when you
used to shoot the ball
of the pinball machine, there
were these little flippers
that kept the -- that's how I
think of history in my books
as little flippers that
are just keeping the ball
within a set of boundaries.
And it's sometimes challenging
to work really closely
in that parameter, but
it's a challenge I enjoy,
how to stretch the truth
without breaking it.
A little bit like magic.
Thanks for your question.
[ Laughter ]
>> A similar question.
Being that you are a researcher
and an academic before
you were a novelist,
at what point do you
stop yourself following
down the rabbit hole of
delicious search in order
to write the actual
words of the novel?
>> Deborah Harkness: OK, so
this is a great question.
I don't stop myself from
falling down a rabbit hole.
If you want to know why there
was a gap between Shadow
of Night and the Book of Life,
it's because I kept falling
down rabbit holes,
scientific rabbit holes,
and not being able
to extricate myself.
So, you know, I spent 2
and a half weeks in Shadow
of Night trying to figure
out how long the voyage
from Woodstock to Europe
would take in November.
I called long distance
eventers who work on horses
over long distances and had
long, complicated discussions
about the speed you --
how long you can canter,
how long you can gallop, when
you have to change horses.
It ended up being one
sentence in Shadow of Night.
[ Laughter ]
Two weeks of unending research.
It was the most frustrating
two weeks.
They don't teach you this
in graduate school,
just so you know.
And so it is one of the
delights of writing a book.
And even though it feels
like a weird rabbit hole,
it almost always
produces something useful.
So now that I have a little
bit more confidence in myself
as a writer, I panic less when
I fall down those rabbit holes.
But it's always a -- where
it's a balancing act is
in the writing.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Deborah Harkness: Because
historical information is
like jalapeno pepper
or cilantro:
a little goes a long way.
So you don't want to sort of
take everything you've learned
about history -- and I know you
have read books like this --
and dump them in so that
it overwhelms the story.
It should be a spice,
a flavoring, an accent.
So one of the things that
I do is I ask myself,
if this story was
set in the present,
would I spend three
pages describing a table?
No, right?
So if I'm in the past, I try to
hold that same standard to it.
That if in fact Diana sits down
at a table in the 16th century,
I don't devote -- I
could devote three pages
to describing the
table, but I try not to.
And that's how I sort
of balance it out.
>> Thank you.
>> Deborah Harkness: Great.
Yeah?
>> Hi. Well, USC
grad, so fight on.
>> Deborah Harkness: Fight on.
>> I hope that Philippe
might get a book in there.
I would love to maybe see
an early version of him.
My question is, I am a leader
of a club of Army spouses,
well-read and well-traveled.
So after we read your new books
and before your newer
ones come out,
what books would you
recommend for us?
>> Deborah Harkness: Wow.
So, you mean, just, like,
what are some of the books
that I'm just loving
reading these days?
>> Exactly.
>> Deborah Harkness: So
I will tell you for --
who has read Eleanor
Oliphant Is Completely Fine?
Give it up to Eleanor Oliphant.
I love that book.
>> Did that.
>> Deborah Harkness: Did that.
[ Laughter ]
I also have to say I just
finished reading Girl,
Wash Your Face, by Rachel
Hollis, which I had a lot
of fun with, and which I felt
at times she was
writing directly to me.
I tend to be a professional
nonfiction reader,
so I'm actually reading
a book about papermaking,
because why not as a
historian of the book,
and I'm enjoying that.
So yeah, those are three off the
top of my head that are right
on my to read pile or
have just read pile.
>> Thank you.
>> Deborah Harkness:
Yeah, you're welcome.
Hi.
>> Hi. I run an apothecary
museum here
in Alexandria right
outside of D.C.
that you should totally come
and visit, 18th, 19th century.
>> Deborah Harkness: OK,
that sounds like fun.
>> There's people
who've been there, also.
And an apothecary, that's
my particular interest.
I'm curious what sources you
used for some of the botany
that you talk about
in the witchcraft
that are in the books.
>> Deborah Harkness: Yeah.
It's a great question.
So I spend, like I
said, lots and lots
of times reading scientific
and medical notebooks.
So I spend lots of
times with notebooks
that medical practitioners
kept of their medical receipts,
their cures, their recipes.
Similarly, I work
on a lot of people
who would have self-identified
as magicians
in the 16th century, and
those include their spells
and their plant lore.
So the Bodleian Library
probably has one
of the biggest collections
and the British Library has
the second biggest collection
for what I do, which
is 16th century.
But I did just buy an early
19th-century medical formulary
on eBay.
>> There's a lot out there.
>> Deborah Harkness: I know,
there's amazing stuff on eBay.
So I'm sort of delving
into the wonderful world
of 19th century drugs
right now and medicines.
>> Come see me.
>> Deborah Harkness: Well,
it's amazing, because again,
this book is, like,
breaking apart.
There's newspaper clippings in
it, there's handwritten recipes,
and it's everything
from veterinary recipes
to headache cures to apple pies.
And I just love it.
You know, but it was clearly
some household's essential text.
>> Well, we have
a massive archive.
So if you are needing
research on American stuff --
>> Deborah Harkness: I
will take you up on that.
>> -- you can [inaudible] --
>> Deborah Harkness: Perfect.
>> -- on Facebook,
and [inaudible].
>> Deborah Harkness: All right.
I will come --
>> Thank you.
>> Deborah Harkness:
-- visit you.
I'll take you up on that.
Yes?
>> Hi, Deborah.
>> Deborah Harkness: Hi there.
>> First of all, thank you.
You've made the last couple
years completely enjoyable late
at night.
>> Deborah Harkness: Oh, thanks.
>> And during the day and
in the middle of the night.
How has all this
changed your life?
How has it impacted you?
>> Deborah Harkness: I
have a bigger classroom,
that's for sure.
I have to make hard
decisions about priorities
that I didn't have to do before.
So when I first started,
you know, I was writing
in the morning between
five and seven.
No one had ever heard of me,
no one knew anything about it,
no one was waiting
for the Philippe book
or the Galloglass book.
And I was just writing in the
morning, and then I would go off
and teach my classes and then
I'd cook dinner and, you know,
pet the dogs and go to sleep
and start the next day.
But now I have a couple of --
you know, in addition to being
a writer and a professor,
I'm an author, which is this
part of my life is coming
and meeting you, which I love.
And I'm also, of course,
working on the TV show
as an executive producer.
So that's a lot of
different hats to wear.
And sometimes I have
to make decisions
about doing one thing
instead of the other
or pushing something aside.
And that is honestly
the hardest part
of my new life is juggling --
but listen, I'm talking to a
whole room of multitaskers.
We're all juggling.
It's just that those are my
particular balls in the air.
So that's my challenge
at the moment.
>> Thank you.
>> Deborah Harkness:
I'm a work in progress.
Hey.
>> Hi.
>> Deborah Harkness: Hi.
>> You referenced sharing
experiences and wanting
to know experiences
with reading,
and you shared a positive one.
Could you share your first or
strongest negative experience
with a book and how that shaped
you as a person and an author?
>> Deborah Harkness: Yes.
I just got chills.
I can tell you when it happened.
It was last spring.
I was teaching the
history of the book,
and one of my students
decided that they wanted
to do a project on Mein Kampf.
And they wanted to do it
because they'd been to a museum
and there was a copy
of Mein Kampf in a --
kind of in a corner in a
museum, a Holocaust Museum.
And they thought that it should
have a more prominent place
in the museum because it
had been so instrumental.
And I said to her,
well, have you looked
and seen how many copies of
Mein Kampf we have here at USC?
So we did, and we discovered
that we had almost two dozen
copies of Mein Kampf at SC.
And I had to put in a request
for Mein Kampf to call them
up out of the stacks
in rare books.
And when I went to pick up
Mein Kampf, I felt like --
first of all, I didn't want
to walk across the library
with this copy of
this book in my hand
because it had a certain
kind of power for me
that was very negative.
And I also felt like
I had to explain
to the librarian
why I was taking it
out because I didn't want
them to think I wanted
to read Mein Kampf because
I liked what it said.
And it gave me an insight
into all of the people
who were afraid to have a
book in their possession
because the power that
book had in public.
I had never -- I could
not understand that.
I could not understand why
somebody would think having a
copy of Copernicus's
work on the revolution
of the spheres would
be dangerous.
And I didn't feel that
until I actually had to go
to my own university library and
ask them to go into rare books
and pull out a copy
of Mein Kampf for me.
So that was my first really
chilling experience with a book
of power in a negative way.
What a great question.
Thank you for asking it.
All right.
We have two minutes.
And we're going to have one --
we're going to try
to get both in.
All right, fast.
>> This will be a
quick question.
>> Deborah Harkness:
Speed round.
OK.
>> OK. Silly, I'm going silly.
>> Deborah Harkness: OK.
>> A couple weeks ago,
you promised us a list
of Matthew's swear words.
>> Deborah Harkness: I know.
[ Laughter ]
It's still on my list.
>> OK.
>> Deborah Harkness:
We will not forget it.
We will get it to
you, I promise.
Yes?
>> Going off the negative books,
I just was wondering what do
you think about Isaac Newton
or if you could speak
about him using, like --
Isaac Newton, and how he would
go to London to travel to get --
what you call it -- censored
books, and he did it in secret,
if you could talk a
little bit about that.
>> Deborah Harkness: Yeah.
Isaac Newton was a great
reader of banned books.
He was also a terrible
defacer of books.
One of the things that
Newton used to do was
to take the corner of books'
pages and he'd bend them
so that the point pointed
to the passage in the book
that he wanted to read.
So you can go through Newton's
old books, and all you have --
they will actually let
you bend the corner down.
There's, like, a crease.
And you can do that and
then see what it was
that he wanted to remember.
Don't do this with
library books, right?
[ Laughter ]
But that was what Newton did.
So he was somebody
who was always
into secret forms of knowledge.
You know, one of the most
humbling things in my life was
to realize that sort of Newton
had devised calculus in 18 days.
But he had spent decades on a
single alchemical experiment.
So what we remember Newton
for is not necessarily what
Newton was spending most
of his time doing, and
that includes his reading.
Because you would think
that what he would be doing
was reading everybody else's
scientific works.
He wasn't.
He was reading other
stuff and then coming
up with scientific
ideas of his own.
He wasn't all that interested
in what his fellow
scientists were doing,
which is why somebody like
Edmond Halley had to go and say,
you know, could we
please have the principia
out of your desk drawer?
Because some of us
would like to read it.
So he was a -- he had a very
interesting relationship
with his books.
He also used to write in
the margins of his books
and between the lines
of his books.
And when he ran out of room,
he'd turn the book around,
and he'd go the other way.
So he was a crafty
old guy, that Newton.
So if any of you are, you
know, personal book defacers,
you come from a long tradition
of great minds like
Isaac Newton.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, great questions.
Wonderful to meet you all.
I hope I see you in
the signing line.
Thanks so much.
[ Applause ]